Speaker 1: Former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie, former Trump endorser Chris Christie
is going to be running against Donald Trump
and the other Republicans in the primary field
for the Republican presidential nomination.
NBC News is now reporting former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie to announce his 2024
presidential bid on Tuesday.
It is Christie's second run for the nomination.
He will announce at a town hall in Manchester,
New Hampshire.
Two sources were confirmed.
The article reminds us that Chris Christie
stumbled is the word they used to a sixth
place finish in 2016 as New Hampshire primary.
Axios was the first to report the timing of
Christie's announcement after he dropped out
of the race eight years ago.
Christie endorsed Trump days before Super
Tuesday, lending a credible name to Trump's
momentum.
Another interesting aspect to this is that
ABC News is immediately suspending its relationship
with Chris Christie.
Chris Christie has been a analysts contributor
sort of person on ABC.
ABC has announced that at least for now, they
are suspending their relationship with Chris
Christie because he is indeed becoming an
official candidate.
So I'm going to be very transparent with everybody
here.
If you came to me maybe with tears in your
eyes and said, David, if you knew that one
of the Republicans currently running would
be the next president of the United States,
who would you pick?
I pick Chris Christie.
And when you say to me, okay, well, there's
Trump, there's DeSantis, Nikki Haley, Tim
Scott and Mike Pence.
Vivek Ramaswamy At this point, I don't even
remember who else is running.
You've got, I guess.
Asa Hutchinson, God forbid.
No, listen, I mean, from this group I go with
Chris Christie.
Chris Christie as a New Jersey governor, a
blue state that sometimes elects Republican
governors in the mode of what we've seen happen
in Massachusetts as well over the years.
William Weld, Mitt Romney.
I can't believe I'm blanking a Charlie Baker
more recently.
I would I would be if you said forget about
Democrats.
It's just it's going to be one of these Republicans.
I think I go with Christie.
I actually think Christie is more intelligent
than a lot of the other people he's running
against.
I will remind folks that this could be a factor
if Christie gets on the debate stage with
Trump.
Christie is actually pretty good in debates.
And remember these moments back from 2016
when Christie really made Marco Rubio look
stupid by pointing out that Rubio is in a
sort of talking point coma, repeating the
same thing over and over and over again.
Remember this classic moment?
Speaker 3: You have not been involved in a
consequential decision where you had to be
held accountable.
You just simply haven't seen what the people
at home to think about this.
That's what Washington, D.C. does.
The drive by shot at the beginning with incorrect
and incomplete information, and then the memorized
25 second speech.
That is exactly what he's.
Unidentified: See.
See, Marco.
Marco.
The thing is this.
Speaker 3: When you're president, United States,
when you're a governor of a state, the memorized
32nd speech where you talk about how great
America is at the end of it doesn't solve
one problem for one person.
Speaker 2: This notion that Barack Obama doesn't
know what he's doing is just not there.
It is.
He knows exactly what.
Speaker 3: The memorized 25 second speech.
Speaker 2: That's there in the campaign.
Speaker 3: You know what she means?
Get into this.
You know what the shame is, Marco?
The shame is that you would actually criticize
somebody for showing up to work, plowing the
streets, getting the trains run back on time
when you've never been responsible for that
in your own life.
Speaker 1: All right.
So listen, Chris Christie can debate.
I would be from an entertainment standpoint,
I would be very interested in seeing the approach
that Christie would take to Trump from a pragmatic
standpoint.
If I had to pick from this group of Republicans,
who is the next president, it would be Chris
Christie.
And I think probably by a long shot.
It is, I think, maybe interesting or important
to note.
There are MAGA people already making fun of
Chris Christie for being obese.
Trump's obese.
It's stunning to me that the supporters of
one obese candidate are making fun of another
candidate for also being obese.
I mean, yes, Christie seems more obese than
Trump.
I saw some tweets going around about Chris
Christie doesn't need to run for president.
He just needs to run.
Like, go out and jog in order to lose weight.
If that's the best that the MAGA people can
come up with against Christie, I actually
am very interested to see whether Chris Christie
can get some traction because he is quick,
he's got a quicker wit, he's smarter, he has
experience as a prosecutor, a sort of experience
that is lacking and in the Republican primary
and might actually be interesting if confronted
with Trump on a debate stage.
So I'm going to be following the Chris Christie
candidacy.
Interesting closely.
And from an interested perspective, if it's
Christie versus Biden, I'm voting for Biden.
Certainly, I agree with Biden much more on
policy.
But I think that that's the most interesting.
You know, Vivek Ramaswamy so boring.
Tim Scott dead on arrival.
Who cares?
Pence Oh, my goodness.
Pence might try to bore the audience into
submission, but Chris Christie, I find a little
bit interesting.
Let me know your thoughts.
Make sure you're subscribed on YouTube at
YouTube.com, slash the David Pacman Show.
We'll take a quick break and be right back